let's uh let's let's do this oh god i
love it so do we want to give a quick
background on this woman
she's bad she's crazy
so she was in uh
some form of of power within florida
with the covet stuff
um and she has had a heart on for
desantis because desantis
just won't shut down won't do mass
mandates whatever
um she was accused of
and subsequently arrest or not arrested
she wasn't arrested had her
devices taken because um she was accused
of using the
uh the the you know everyone's phone has
the amber alert the national emergency
or state emergency system that which is
weird that they just let us do they let
them do that but whatever
that's that's a different story um she
was using that system that she had
access to
because the position she was in with
grantor access she hacked the mainframe
in real time
she did and which is weird because it
was a gibson and penn jillette was a
security guy
so she was using that to send stuff
saying
fight back there's people dying
basically trying to shame desantis using
that the national broadcasting system on
people's phones so
uh from the story i read uh the police
when
state police went to her home they got
her devices because they said what she
was doing obviously it's a felony
you're not you can't use you know oh
really can hack state-run
emergency broadcast devices weird it's
like a little-known law that's weird
yeah so um here's what happened
uh she was on uh
new york governor's brothers show you
remember rebecca jones no
data scientist fired by the florida
department of health in may after
question actually would be great
if this segment started off for 10
minutes of come on you remember rebecca
right the girl blonde girl florida and
somebody going no no the doc you know
the doctor the covert thing
florida the she had the data
well anyways fired by the florida
department of health in may after
questioning state officials commitment
to accessibility
and transparency with 19 data
well today her home was rated as part of
a
cyber crime investigation video of the
raid
here you can see officers coming in guns
drawn
come outside outside who else is in the
house man my two children
and my husband where's your husband calm
down you want the children now
call them all down mr jones come down
the stairs
now
[Music]
don't you point that gun to my daddy
pointed by the way nobody pointed a gun
to children no
no not at all so the question is why
why because why did the police shoot the
children of this poor woman
why did governor ron desantis drive to
this woman's house and rapper in front
of her ring camera
let's see what they did wrong let's see
what she did wrong mike for an exclusive
interview thank you for joining us
thank you chris she is a [ __ ] lunatic
you can tell
she is a i'm sorry i'm going to say my
opinion
is women or even men
that i've seen that have eyes like that
are usually lunatics
yeah if they're not because it's a
simple matter of
what somebody's focusing on and you can
look at what somebody's focusing on
and when they're looking through you
it's that's not a good sign it's a good
thing she had that camera facing the
door when they came in
and how did she get that camera to get
ready well the police didn't just bust
her door down they were trying for 20
minutes knocking on the door
and calling her phone that's what i read
too yeah and not only that i pointed out
last night
i'd really like to find out i'd like to
get a copy of the receipt for when that
camera was bought and put in because
i have a feeling if you went to that
house and look with that cameras mounted
there's probably fresh drill holes
there's probably you know what i mean
that [ __ ] is brand new like it's just
odd that it's like whoa we just had this
one camera set up
why don't they have a ring camera why
don't they have an upstairs cat why
is it just this one camera to show them
coming in and then
all of a sudden as soon as they're not
on camera she's like they [ __ ] they
pistol-whipped my seven-year-old and
stuck a gut at the joke on nightwave
last night was they stuck a crack
but like she's just making up all this
crazy [ __ ] but in the video
and i pointed this out last night you
can tell first of all the cops
are being a little bit rude and gruff of
course but that only adds credence to
their version of events which is hey we
went there we showed them the warrant we
were calling them
and we knew they were inside they were
trying to be cute
uh i was talking about how in the last
year cops have had
a lot of [ __ ] to deal with and if
there's one thing more frustrating like
you think they're
tough on black men or whatever there's
anything a cop doesn't want to deal with
it's a privileged white woman
it's in this kind of scenario so she
because white people are more likely to
be like
no no i'm not doing it i want to talk to
your supervisor and lock themselves in
the house
so wait the way he comes in kind of
makes me feel like
he has been sitting out there for 20
minutes and he goes come on let's go
outside let's [ __ ]
let's go i've had it that's how it seems
anyway
black guy is like a dollar she dude
that's that's not a she's hitting you
the right accusation and so she's
already above you
then her eyes turn white
it sucks because more and more women in
this day and age
that are actually like she's not bad
looking she's not like
she's a pretty good looking chick but
like there's a lot of
decent looking chicks that you just
gotta cut your losses and walk away from
like
you have one drink with them and i'm
learning it's safer in 2020 to go anyway
have a great night i just feel i got to
work in the morning
so you know hey i'll buy you another
have a good evening thank you yeah and
you're just like no you can see it in
the eyes it's going to be a
week why do you think this happened
after speaking to my attorneys and
looking over
there the evidence they said they have
um
i actually think that they're not after
me they didn't take the router
in my house they didn't take a number of
laptops in the house that belonged to my
son or my husband
that could have easily done whatever it
is that they think happened
they took my phone and they took the
computer that i used to run my companies
well
probably and just because look i'm not a
computer expert here
but probably because whatever you did
you didn't use a vpn
which is what you should have done they
said the ip went right to our house and
it was probably had the mac address for
that specific computer
on it well not only that i will go a
step further and there's somebody who
has cops in my family and there's
somebody who's very very interested in
that
realm of things cops can't just go
hey we think this person did something
we need a warrant for every computer
that's not how it works warrants need to
be narrow and specific
and that's how they work so when you go
to a judge you go look
we think she used this laptop in this
house
there might be a thumb drive or two we
need to but you can't just go we want a
warrant for everything or kid
i want a kid's school drawings i want
everything that's in that kid's room too
i want to go through every drawer now
they can't do that so they usually go
yeah that we think it's this woman doing
it and they let you take a handful of
devices now's a good time to talk about
expressvpn i'm kidding
and on my phone is every communication
i've ever had
with someone who works at the state who
has come to me in confidence and told me
things that could get them fired
or in trouble like this and i just want
to say to all those people right now
if he doesn't know already desantis will
know soon enough that you've been
talking to me
she's what does that mean by the way i'm
sorry are we ignoring her eyebrows
no they're hilarious but no so she's
she's doing this whole thing like
uh if he doesn't know now soon he's
gonna know i've been speaking to you
this is all fun to her this is all some
of course i can feel important i'm in an
i'm in a mr robot episode
but it's not really it is you know i'm
right
she watches an alex cross novel you know
she wants that
so bad she wants to be a jack ryan
character so bad like a house of cards
character
listen i don't have long oh my gosh
listen
listen they might be watching me right
now
over here look the files are in the
garbage can
over there i can't be seen talking to
you any longer good day
ma'am this is the wendy's excuse me do
you know what time it is
sir who i don't know who totally doesn't
work for the nsa
when lydia sits and better call sarah
breaking bad when lydia sits
on the opposite booth behind mike and he
goes just [ __ ] over here
come over here and get a coffee
because like mike understands it's even
more like yeah like the lydia
thing's great because anybody that's
ever tried the first time they've ever
tried to sell a bag of dope or something
or do something illegal
they're always really jumpy because
you're not used to it and a cop will
tell you
no if you're gonna have a criminal
conspiracy sit down and order a grilled
cheese
and talk you're gonna blend into a diner
much more easily
but yeah she's doing this look i can't
be seen talking to you
there's no there's very little time
[Laughter]
she wants to be that person so bad the
thing was with her is her hair says
privileged white women but her eyebrows
says ms-13
yeah so i can't really figure out what
she is the way those are drawn on her
eyebrows say
ms
[Laughter]
did zack aynor put those on with his
feet
jesus okay come on this is dude this is
a criminal conspiracy we're trying to
uncover here
why are you taking this seriously so be
careful
uh they say you know i don't know if you
know these guys
rice is right this is serious see our
governor here in florida is a fascist
and he kicked in the door of one woman
in front of her family around christmas
time
politely called so that he didn't have
to kick in the doors of every single
other citizen in the state of florida
for the entire month of christ having a
birthday party for having a birthday
party sounds to me like desantis picked
the lesser of two evil
so wait i only got a kick in one door
and then christmas is saved
go get that broad drag her back macer i
don't care whatever you got to do
santa's coming what if what if desantis
really just believes in santa
the santa baby what if desantis really
is just this child like
no we can't close down santa's coming
soon enough that you've been talking to
me so be careful
uh be careful it's disappearable hey oh
what are you so what are you
what are you trying to say is that uh
the desantis family is going to have me
whacked
so now the desantis family is going to
have the cuomo's brothers whacked off
because if the comb if you whack off the
cuomo brothers
then they move you to a different police
department because they don't want you
[ __ ]
yeah but what if i want to go into the
hardware get with those sandwiches i
like
you can't you just you're on the list
with al capone
no but it's so like this is so silly
you're in danger hey oh whoa oh
whoa first of all ain't nobody gonna lay
[ __ ] hands on me
all right in this thing of ours
come on this is real
so be careful uh they say you know
you've seen this but for the audience
they say you know be great right now she
fakes her own
death on like she tries really badly
to try to fake being yeah on cat oh
ow boom and she's like oh god and then
she cuts the camera
she does the camera trick where she
chokes herself like someone else is
choking her
oh no she's got squibs
that are really badly done
oh and she like overdoes it and then
disconnects the webcam
and cuomo just sitting there going this
is a [ __ ] oh my god
the santas is from santa
so he's the son of santa jesus christ
that's crazy bro i'm ron son of santa
all right come on this is a real thing
they say
that they believe that an ip address
belonging to you was used to access an
emergency system within the state
that you weren't supposed to have access
to anymore once you weren't working
there
where you put out a message telling
people to speak up speak out about covid
speak out about the deaths
did you send that text on that system no
i haven't had access to any systems at
doh for
over six months i'm not a hacker as
the governor you don't have to be a
hacker you just have to have previously
had access
you just have to have access to the
system it just means you could still log
in yeah i've i've gotten into things i
wasn't supposed to have access to
anywhere
it's but it's just you have things that
you know the company's gonna wipe that
are your files and you're like no i'm
getting back in there but that doesn't
require hacking
which for over six months i'm not a
hacker
as the governor pointed out many months
ago i'm not that tech savvy
and have no interest in reaching out to
doh i've been publicly telling people to
come forward for months
that is the way i do it and i better
than anybody know that people at dh
aren't going to
lying and here's the thing i know
somebody's kind of joking in the chat
uh grim reaper says lol they wouldn't
arrest you then if you didn't do it
which i mean is obviously i mean
they can't make these things up of
course you can't no no i agree i agree
this whole scenario
is plausible of course the government
can do this absolutely they can
but this bit and they've done it to
people before i will i will concede
they can smear you look what they did to
gary webb gary webb's the best example
of a governor
government just stabbing a citizen in
the back for just telling the truth
but like gary webb didn't have a whole
history of mental illness and arrests
leading up to him exposing the crack in
cia connections what are you talking
about
what do you mean history are you saying
she's had issues before this
uh there's been a couple of um incidents
oh cool name four
well we'll let her finish it but they're
i'm just saying there may have been a
couple
you're right we should let her finish
that that's all i'm out before
when i warned everybody that desantis
would and eventually he did get people
killed
yes santa's got people killed he
literally
yeah he just did you not hear he already
put a [ __ ] hit out on the cuomo
brothers
you know desantis was in his office
going i want him dead
i want his family dead i want his kids
dead i know
we're all fit i know we're focused on
her but can you can you tell who also is
not buying this
coma look at him i'm being serious and i
hate como but i'll
look at him just look at him real quick
well that's you know what that look is
that look is ten minutes ago we thought
we had something
and we have nothing quickly dawning on
me that this is unraveling yeah and now
i look like an [ __ ]
if they didn't come out before when i
warned everybody that desantis
would and eventually he did get people
killed they're not going to come out now
what do you mean desantis is at the
governor's mansion right now
like ordering his wife around like tony
soprano and being like make sure go
upstairs and get those records too we
got to get rid of him and give me give
me a necklace and give me those rings
and then she's like what about my
wedding ring that's not stolen and then
he just pauses and she's like
she's just totally mobbed up what if
it's the cuomo's versus the desantis can
somebody write this script for me
you make if they're saying that they
have the ip address and that is yours
well that ip address is apparently
provided by the department of health
ig office expect inspector general and
didn't actually come from an
investigation into doh
well because doh
when you're when you because a lot of
these people were remote working
doh department of health would have
the ip address of the people accessing
their system remotely no they wouldn't
they wouldn't have this wouldn't they no
oh you're right i'm an idiot
it was a hacker and she's not a hacker
royce oh she said it
she's not an actor you don't think a
hacker could fake an ip address dude
now i don't know how big a deal it is to
send that text
i'd have to look closer at the statute
it's a huge deal
look i don't understand these like
computers and uh
i you know look i i got my phone you
know what i mean i do the emails and
stuff on there but i don't really
you know i'm not really big into the
computers my kids though you know they
they love that [ __ ] shoot and see what
they saw in terms of why they're
motivated this way
um but you do know that saying you
didn't send it if they proved that you
did
you're going to have much bigger
problems
yeah and if
this this is my point about como if you
say you didn't send it and you prove
that you did you can have a bigger
problem
because now you're a lot now you're
lying on national tv who's her attorney
by the way
because if the first thing a lawyer
would tell you is
don't go on the news don't say anything
a good attorney whether you did it or
not by the way whether you did it or not
a good attorney would tell you you don't
say anything yeah
i'm i'm not too worried about that you
stand by the answer you did not send
that text you did not send any message
of any kind
to any group on any system that you
weren't supposed to
the only direct communication i've ever
sent to doh was through a public op-ed
in the miami herald asking people to
speak out and that was many months ago
and you know why i'm asking you it's not
about an accusation is i want to give
you
fair uh hearing to answer what they're
going to put out and have put out about
why they came to your house
that way and i heard you freaking out
about your kids being in there and what
they do i understand why you'd be
worried about it
but they're saying it's a cyber crime
you're saying there's nothing to their
allegation
no and this is just a very thinly veiled
attempt of the governor to intimidate
scientists
and get back at me while trying to get
to my sources as he's been firing doh
staff
left and right well no i'm sorry you've
made all that up in your head and why do
you keep looking over to the left
because she's crazy and she's lying and
when you
lie royce you look up and to the left
and that's legit
like she can't even by the way even when
she's giving up like
unlying tells they're so over the top
that it's ridiculous like i would you
know what i would i would love
to play poker with this woman playing
poker with this woman would be
the easiest gig in the world you would
be fleecing this woman all night she
just cannot help this
it's really bad their director of
communication i'm sorry the right you're
right
it's it's whatever you're right you're
right to the right about that time
do you know the communication that
they're talking about did you hear about
it do you have any sense of who might
have sent it
i didn't even see it until today and i'd
also like to note that
a lot of the language that was used in
it is not the way i talk
and the number of deaths that the person
used wasn't even right
they were off they were actually under
by about 430 deaths
i would never round down 430 deaths
those are 430 people who have died in
the state
is that but it's that is that is that
her
type of spelling errors her so her
excuses it had spelling errors and i
would never talk that way
and i also love that her defense is like
i'm a scientist but also
no no no no i'm way too much of a
hysterical
to round numbers like scientists do all
the time by the way
they they scientists round numbers all
the time
they don't do it when you break open the
study itself
but when a scientist is in front of the
pr like the press doing a press
conference
they're not going to go we had 17 430
debt they're going to go
we've had over 17 000 deaths in the
county and we need to do something about
they don't you know what i mean like
she her defense is i'm crazy
seriously that's her her defense is i'm
crazy
and i'm very difficult to deal with in a
professional and a personal setting
that's what she's telling us right now i
take that number
and every number i publish very
seriously
so listen i don't want to draw this out
too much i know you got loyalty because
you know this is turning out to be a
real [ __ ] disappointment so
we're going to cut this segment short
but i don't want to say that
they're you know they're always going to
be worried about people coming on
television when you have a case pending
but i wanted to give you an opportunity
to respond to the allegations in real
time as they're going out there
and i'm sure that this was a hard day uh
for your family especially if there's
nothing behind the allegations
last word to you desantis needs to worry
less
about what i'm writing about and more
about the people who are sick and dying
in his state
and doing this to me will not stop me
from reporting the data
nobody know knew who you were up until
this
did anybody know who this woman was
nobody cared about you you
you weren't on national news nobody knew
who you were
this is why you're famous this is why
you're famous you weren't famous before
this
so that's suspect right there now
um what are some things that have
happened here in the past
well i want to thank uh jpc rotc for uh
doing such a good job digging this up
uh here's a little bit of a background
on that rebecca jones on
june 13 2016 rebecca jones was booked on
one count of battery on a police officer
one count of remaining after forbidden
and
i guess trespassing in a weird county uh
and two counts of resisting arrest while
she was a staff member at louisiana
state university
that was from the louisiana lsu
whatever whatever their paper is so that
was
one uh looking good that's what she had
regular eyebrows
yeah that's uh uh and then from the
ocala post on may 21
2020 um rebecca jones
this is according to the alcala post
rebecca jones created a revenge site
posted nudes of a man oh a police report
obtained by the ocala post from
tallahassee
rebecca jones the woman who claimed she
was fired from the doh for refusing to
falsify kova 19 data
has an open criminal investigation for
sexual cyber harassment and cyber
stalking
the charge came after a man who
previously had a restraining order
against jones
said she created a revenge poor revenge
porn website and posted nude photos of
him
according to the police report jones
shared the website with the man's
employer family and friends
after initially refusing to answer
questions about rebecca jones governor
ron desantis finally spoke out about her
during a press conference
santa says she didn't listen to people
who are superiors come to find out
she's also under active criminal charges
in the state of florida she's being
charged with cyber stalking and cyber
sexual harassment
while the doh still refuses to answer
any questions desantis
said he is asking questions as to why
jones was allowed to stay
on while she was facing criminal charges
so this woman
and i i love somebody sent this to me
like breaking last night and i was
breaking this down on night wave
i looked at this picture for maybe two
minutes
and not having seen any of this jpc rotc
thank you so much for sending this but
he sent it like
after the show he was just i was just
checking his
all his links and stuff and so i had no
idea who this
was and i mean called it to a [ __ ] t
this is crazy dude
like that's dude already had restraining
orders and again this is what i was
bringing up when we were when we were
playing the clip like
you know gary webb when he exposed the
government for
for you know basically trafficking
cocaine into the country
and and just creating crack um
when they destroyed gary webb's life
everything they had on gary webb was
like
like all of a sudden he was an alcoholic
and a woman beater and all this stuff
but there was not like years leading up
to gary webb's story where he was also a
[ __ ] mess and he was already
had restraining orders and arrests like
this woman
has been a [ __ ] wacko for a long time
she has an established
record of being a wacko apparently she's
also lied about being an architect and a
scientist behind the
florida kova dashboard she said she
built the site from scratch the
dashboard was actually created by ersie
a company providing geographical
information and system software
also if she's not tech savvy she was
apparently allegedly tech savvy enough
to make a revenge porn site for her
i'm not a hacker i guess um
i think that she knows i don't know man
look who knows
you know maybe she didn't do it of
course nobody knows i'm just saying that
sure but um there she is and
she's definitely not as cute as you
think she is she looks
[ __ ] nuts
someone says scuff sarah connor
uh some frozen nation says mercer's
future ex-wife
no no no too hot for you no i don't i'm
too sexy
i don't [ __ ] with them kind of
crazy i'm sorry what are them kind of to
ones with [ __ ] pinhole eye
[ __ ] pupils and [ __ ] the ones that
the ones that are like yeah and uh
and then the governor he's been after me
for years like you know sorry
not interested